[Música]
turno de la cultura en france 24 hoy
rendida al juego del calamar
mundialmente titulada squid game la
serie ha devuelto a este cajón de la
narrativa gamer en el que la caza se
funde con la atrocidad cuál es entonces
su aporte que lo cuenta con un humor no
tan visto en el registro pero sobre todo
permite pensar la sociedad capitalista
desde un espacio infantil en el que
hacer amigos cuesta la vida y deja sin
el mayor premio saldar deudas
sí
hayward a la felicidad
esta es la competencia a la que se
enfrentan y en la que hasta el heroico
protagonista sabe que el costo su
humanidad pero claro aunque los juegos
parezcan la arena de batalla el infierno
es la desigualdad del día a día que en
corea del sur ahoga miles de personas ya
lo trató la oscarizada para side salvo
que aquí le ocurrió hasta el creador
guangdong fuck que ha logrado acercar al
mundo desde una galleta de alguna es
decir desde la tradición coreana aún
cuando la serie indigna o ha
capitalizado sus escenarios los k dramas
son hoy los mejores en radiografiar
nuestra inmundicia moral
a veces es muy violento pero creo que
sales de la serie sintiéndote agradecida
por los pequeños actos de bondad que
recibes a diario y que das a los demás
creo que definitivamente anima a la
gente a ser más amable con los demás
el contenido coreano ha llegado para
quedarse con para site y piti es y squid
cane no creo que nadie pueda seguir
ignorándolo creo que hay una razón por
la que netflix y festiva y disney ya pod
están invirtiendo todo este dinero en
contenido coreano porque están aquí para
quedarse y va a llevarse una parte más
grande del dólar del entretenimiento los
servicios de streaming han ampliado las
miradas mientras que el valencia se
puede ver a 360 grados y con los ojos de
toulouse lautrec tal inmersión lleva la
firma del coreógrafo francés que adabel
acv y quien por primera vez en el mundo
ha unido danza con lentes y cámaras de
realidad virtual para una creación sobre
el pintor lejos de sustituir el showman
o su interés era anexar escenas 3d de
dos minutos para acercar las tablas y
dibujar un cantan y un martes al estilo
de toulouse dot cake su alma de guayo le
permitió observar la intimidad y
plasmarla en obras y carteles y aquí
somos de otra ex sintiendo casi piel a
piel música burdel y gestos de
bailarines
[Música]
elegir talento de antaño es la emisión
que se ha trazado el museo berlinés
vervoordt gym con su nacional luís stops
durante la segunda guerra mundial los
nazis prohibieron sus esculturas
truncando una libertad que solo desde
1928 pudo empezar a gozar ya divorciada
y formada en arte sin embargo el horror
el dolor y el derribo de su estudio
dieron paso a una postguerra que igual
marginó a las artistas mujeres lo que
hasta 1988 no frenó a estos exhibida al
fin como escultura del siglo 20
e
no abandonamos este pasado y presente
que se da en la mano ya que el filme de
las duelo de ridley scott contiene a
todos los stops de la historia a partir
de una violación el estreno no ha tenido
gran campaña pero es una de las mejores
construcciones de scott quien recrea el
último duelo a muerte documentado en
europa a raíz del abuso que sufrió
marguerite de tipo vil el combate
ocurrió en 1386 en parís entre el
caballero expuesto de mca game y un
escudero protegido por un poderoso conde
no obstante el reto se da en salvaguarda
de la masculinidad quien gana tiene la
razón la verdad y no por la violencia
vivida por la afectada que es
cuestionada como hoy desde todos los
ángulos
[Música]
a mí
es normal
[Música]
ah
dun será nuestro próximo comentario
cinéfilo que ha sido tan anhelada como
los discos de los británicos elton john
y adele el gran ser de la música no
disfrutaba de un álbum colaborativo
desde 2012 mientras que la reina de las
baladas no hacía lo propio desde 2015
pero justo ese año el compositor belga
stromae fue mucho más tajante en su
silencio y dijo basta de notas al
estallar de desgaste laboral hasta ahora
que constante que se puede leer como
salud propia y como brindis ha decidido
regresar y alzar su voz por la gente
común por las rosas al verse y se links
que trabajan cuando otros bailan
celebrando su vuelta desde la finca gay
de 2013 nos despedimos cuídense mucho y
muchas gracias
[Música]
sufro de camiones
to lose imagen fiscal
negociación de piel sobre el balón de
falta
de soñar de una ficción y yo sé qué
depende que hay un parque de pasión
[Música]
sí no